pas et puis nous avons maintenant
souhaiter si vous le voulez bien un bon
anniversaire à tintin vous savez le
copain du capitaine haddock qui a 70 ans
aujourd'hui mais n'a pas pris une ride
pour les amateurs de ses aventures
toujours aussi nombreux mais nous non
plus d'ailleurs n'a pas perdu un poil
les péripéties de nos trois héros se
sont vendus à ce jour à 200 millions
d'exemplaires des albums qui révèlent
parfois d'étranges secret à ceux qui
savent lire entre les bulls à brice
turpin frédéric bobin même dans tintin
la vérité serait d'ailleurs partant du
constat que les enfants dessinent
souvent les secrets dont ils ne peuvent
pas parler
le psychanalyste serge tisseron a essayé
de l'appliquer au monde des adultes
il y a une vingtaine d'années juste
avant de mourir hergé avait avoué qu'il
avait mis toute sa vie dans tintin et en
disséquant les 24 albums d'hergé
le psychanalyste a découvert son secret
de ce secret qui court tout au long de
l'an tueur de tintin c'est l'histoire
d'un garçon qui est né de père inconnu
mais de père illustre et précisément ça
se trouve dans le secret de la licorne
et le trésor de rackham le rouge ou le
chevalier de hadoque est donné très
clairement pour être l'ancêtre du
capitaine haddock mais il est donné très
clairement aussi pour être le fils
bâtard de louis xiv nous y voilà
consciemment ou inconsciemment hergé
fait référence à sa propre histoire
révélée par deux journalistes belges car
sa grand-mère simple servant au château
du comte de du dell avait donné
naissance à deux jumeaux alexis son père
et leon sans jamais leur révéler le nom
de leurs géniteurs
aujourd'hui la rumeur prétend que cet
illustre inconnu pourrait être léopold
ii le roi des belges fiction réalité le
personnage énigmatique de la castafiore
sème encore un peu plus le doute surtout
quand elle joue le rôle de marguerite
dans l'opéra debout
marguerite de l'opéra de gounod c'est un
personnage étonnant parce que c'est une
femme de milieu modeste qui tombe
amoureuse d'un homme de conditions
beaucoup plus élevée que la sienne qui
se retrouve enceinte en dehors de tout
mariage et qui finit par en mourir
et cette marguerite de l'opéra de gounod
exactement même destin que la grand mère
de hergé mari de vie hergé lui se
seraient identifiés à trois de ses
personnages tintin le reporter détective
qui résout les mystères le capitaine
haddock alcoolique délinquants et
colérique parce qu ils se désespèrent de
trouver un jour la vérité est enfin
tournesol qui a décidé de se couper du
monde trois facettes de l'introspection
psychanalytique
tournons la page